and this is one of the best examples of
a phenomenon we talk about from time to
time people tend to glaze over so we're
going to try to do it this time in a way
that keeps them from glazing over you've
got three years left on a contract when
whenever someone gets an extension and
in this case it's a two-year extension
there isn't a new two-year contract that
gets stapled onto the back end of the
three-year contract you already have so
you finish those three years and oh look
i'm starting on my two-year extension no
that's not how it works they rip up the
three years that remain and they do a
new five-year contract that's always the
case it's never an extra contract that
gets added to the old contract it's
always a new contract and in this case
when you have three years left and you
only get two more years you know usually
it's you have one year left right and
you get five more years yeah so it makes
sense to pay attention to those five
years not the one that you have left in
this case you still got the majority of
the old deal from a duration standpoint
that's left and i think that's the way
we need to look at deandre hopkins
because what a difference chris when you
look at two years 54.5 million well
that's
27.25 million per year that makes him
the highest paid non-quarterback in nfl
history yeah right yeah yeah but when
you look at the five-year contract it's
in line with amari cooper in fact it's
less total value than amari cooper if
you look at a fresh five-year contract
that he's getting as he walks through
the door as a member of the cardinals so
that's the difference here and you're
going to hear superlatives on one end
and on the other end you're going to
hear reality and reality is it's a
five-year deal worth about 18 million
maybe it's four years 1975 there's a
voidable year we don't know the trigger
yet to make that fifth year go away but
it's not julio jones it's not the
greatest contract ever given to any
player who isn't a quarterback it just
isn't it may look that way at first
glance but when you look at it more
closely it's not it's still what he
wanted right and the texans weren't
going to give it to him but it's not as
tremendous as summer making it out to me
yeah i i hear you mike well first off i
mean you know way to go arizona
cardinals you trade a guy trade for a
guy like deandre hopkins you know well
yes
don't wait you know this is on the
horizon and he's going to be a big part
of your offense get out in front of it
get it done now especially in this
offense with kyler murray i think we're
all expecting him to explode a little
bit i'd be a little scared of a guy like
deandre hopkins maybe leading the league
in receptions this year then commanding
more money next year so uh good for them
on that part as far as deandre hopkins
is concerned really good for him yeah i
mean you know i know him a little bit
he's a great guy
tough as hell
good teammate and i think the thing that
i respect about deandre hopkins and and
just knowing him a little bit i don't
think he gives a damn about some of all
that other stuff you know that's what i
think is cool about i think he's got a
little bit of a a lunch pail workmen
like attitude to him where you know it's
not about like hey i gotta puff out my
chest and i gotta be the top paid wide
receiver in football you know for a year
or five months or
i have to hit a certain number to
justify where i am no he obviously
wanted more money he wasn't looking to
just absolutely crush the arizona
cardinals that way he is a team player i
think he realizes he needs a team around
him and wants to build something there
and from that standpoint i give him
credit and i give arizona both credit
for for getting this done and now
squashing it and now you don't have to
worry about it or talk about it anymore
whether it's five years 94 million in
comparison to murray cooper's five years
100 million or four years 79 million
which is just under 20 million per year
average 42 million guaranteed at signing
for hopkins versus 40 million guaranteed
at signing for cooper you give me those
two contracts i'm taking hopkins
100 out of 100 times yeah right right
because it's relatively similar
financial investment and hopkins i think
is dramatically better than cooper don't
you i do i i mean yes
that's where i look at this and you look
at deandre hopkins in a lot of ways and
go like
well you know what a cool guy because he
certainly could have sat there and
commanded no i i deserve more money per
year than amari cooper from what i've
done for what i'm still doing whatever
that may be i stay i'm healthy i play on
the field all the time those are
questions about amari cooper you know
about amari cooper so yeah i'm with you
all the way there i think uh deandre
hopkins is better than mari cooper yes
and and see the other side of it is
the cardinals just could have said
you're under contract for three more
years
play for us or play for no one but
they've given up a second round pick and
david johnson to get him not that they
wanted to keep david johnson it actually
benefited the cardinals to unload his 10
million dollar salary but having those
three years left made it easier for the
cardinals to pay him less on that total
five years or four years however it
shakes out he also got a commitment that
there won't be a franchise tag used on
the back end now five years from now i
don't know that he'd fall into that
group of players that there would be a
land rush for when they come to free
agency because he's gonna be five years
older yeah but uh but still it you know
it it's a it's what he wanted the texans
weren't going to give it to him that's
why the texans traded him
and i i think that even when you look at
this deal
comparable financially to what amari
cooper got
the texans position would still be yeah
we knew that's what it would have taken
we just we just we didn't want to do it
for whatever reason right whether they
want desean watson to diversify the
offense and not constantly look for
deandre hopkins or whether there was
some stuff behind the scenes that maybe
the texans didn't like and didn't see a
long-term future between hopkins and and
the the organization yeah right friction
between hopkins and bill
o'brien should see there's there's
rumors there talk about that yeah right
there's been rumors about that
definitely and i think between that and
you know then billy o'brien and the
texans realizing that he wanted more
money and that was going to be you know
something that was going to have to be
talked about or dealt with yeah they
decided okay hey maybe it would be
better if we went wide receiver by
committee and expanded our offense that
way and we can't have the highest paid
left tackle in football the highest paid
quarterback in football
and then
one of the two or three highest paid
receivers in football too that would be
very hard to build a football team that
way and uh you know really you can you
can have two out of the three but three
out of three could really handcuff you
there and and make some problems for
your roster
and you will hear people say that
deandre hopkins negotiated the deal
himself i just want to be
you know uh accurate factually here's
what happened with this trend of players
negotiating their own contracts russell
okung initially negotiated a contract by
himself and got destroyed by the denver
broncos richard sherman negotiated a
contract by himself and even though he's
still a member of the 49ers and he's
been making the money that he was
promised it was not the kind of deal
that protected him the way it should
have it was not a good deal that is
generally accepted since then
okung
he got help behind the scenes when he
negotiated his deals on his own and
there's there's a belief in league
circles that the same folks who helped
okung helped hopkins behind the scenes
behind the curtain and i don't know why
they're being so secretive about it
but that's the reality and so a lot of
these guys when you hear they
represented themselves they really
didn't they just used a different model
than hiring an agent and giving the
agent one percent two percent i think
the maximum fee is still three percent
of the total value of the contract
because god for whatever reason guys
don't understand
if you give the agent a small percentage
of the pie
there's a chance that agent is going to
get you a much larger pie where 97 of it
is still more than 100 of what you're
going to get on your own or with some
advisors lurking in the background guys
still don't understand that i just don't
want to give up that one two or three
percent chris yeah no you're right they
don't i think a lot of the guys look at
some of these contracts and think you
know they write themselves there's a few
little wrinkles in it that i might need
to be aware of but other than that you
know a contract's a contract and as we
know it's not there is there's a lot of
nuance to it agents or agents because
they're good at it they're good deal
makers they know how to protect their
clients i will say this
you know with a guy like deandre hopkins
and this type of deal it seemed a little
easier maybe than other ones we've seen
that you have to work out at least as
far as that's concerned and you know the
other what do you mean it took six
months well okay i mean it's a new team
he just got there i don't know how like
did they jump right into it when did the
real serious conversation start okay but
either way well remember remember he was
missing practices yes he was holding in
right right so i just i don't know when
it got serious but you're right we knew
this was coming but my other my other
point was
it's kind of cool that he wanted to do
this because he has front office
aspirations which i'm never gonna you
know fault a guy for trying to expand
his horizons and and get a look
underneath the hood to see okay let me
get a little experience how do you do
this how are deals made how do these
conversations go on between gm's players
and agents uh so i respect them for that
at least
let me just say this before we move on i
don't want to go to next level
conspiracy theory but but
consider
two realities one
teams would love it if guys represent
themselves definitely they would love it
they want guys to represent themselves
they want guys to be emboldened to
represent themselves because they know
that if players represent themselves
they're going to be able to set the
price they're going to be able to talk
the players into doing what they want
the players to do they're more likely to
win at the bargaining table if the
players don't have a traditional agent
and secondly
and and this is the next level mini
conspiracy when you look at which media
entities are hyping this deal the most
as this tremendous deal look at the
connections from that entity back to the
league and it's it is the league so
that that's my that's my wednesday
morning conspiracy theory you can put
that in your center square on your bingo
card
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports